also leute wir sind jetzt hier auf dem
instagram akon von marie wirklich ein
schöner kommt erst mal und jetzt darfst
du halt bilder auswählen von ok hey was
geht ab und jetzt bekommen bei einem
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut und zwar falls ihr das
letzte video noch nicht gesehen habt ich
hab mir auch diese niedriger bestellt im
märz ging es darum was ganz anderes aber
heute habe ich mir gedacht wenn ich
dieses gerät jetzt schon mal gekauft hat
460 euro muss man das ja auch nutzen
oder deswegen gibt es heute ein weiteres
video mit dem trecker und diesmal eine
ja ich sag mal so nennen die habe ich
jetzt so nicht erfunden oder was heißt
so nicht erfunden also es gibt ja schon
mega viele videos wo youtuber oder
irgendwelche leute sich so videos
anschauen von so sollte rod girl
compilation meister gibt es von denen
ich dass wir machen etwas anderes
nein und ich habe mir gedacht wenn wir
jetzt schon mal hier ist dann machen wir
doch mal eine andere stadt oder sonst
was ist eigentlich wirklich lustig und
ich bin auch sehr gespannt
ich zeige jetzt gleich marie meint
instagram man darf ihr bilder auswählen
und man sieht ja genau wo sie hin schaut
und dann darf marie ihr instagram ihr
zeigen und mir bilder zeigen weiß wie
ich meine
und dann siehst du ganz genau wo ich als
erstes hinschauen und mein bruder ist
auch dabei wenn devil darf der auch noch
mal mitmachen
wir zeigen also ich würde sagen will
aber gar nicht lange her da schon eine
schöne fotos premiere weil es mir auf
instagram an ich wollte erst einmal alex
wir müssen jetzt kurz dok filmerin den
profil anlegen so jetzt müssen wir
seinen namen angeben für dich
also leute wie ihr sehen könnt wir sind
hier schon auch beim instagram profil
generell von mir irgendwie was und jetzt
bin ich wirklich mal gespannt also muss
ja sagen dass diese bilder eher
langweilig zu informieren deswegen also
ich hab schon wirklich sehr lange nichts
schönes mehr gepasst deswegen müssen wir
ein bisschen weiter runter scrollen
wir fangen einfach mal ganz spontan
hiermit an was also du willst mir jetzt
sagen dass du die ganze zeit einfach
stumpf auf meinen also unsere gesichter
und jetzt komme ich auch meine ich hatte
direktor an das hingekriegt okay egal wo
jetzt so wäre schon ganz schön hast
wahrscheinlich so hässlich welches dass
das hier keine roten augen bei der nase
die da über die mainzer groß auf den
lippen als er zum lippenstift drauf und
dann diese komischen brille
hast du dir dabei gedacht weil sie nicht
und die haare rp aber krass dass du
immer direkt so dass ich glück gehabt
weil das gesicht aber ich gucke immer
wenn menschen als aller erstes das
gesicht an
das würde selbst an diesem tag ist er
hey das ist jetzt schon so alt hier die
bilder hier schon ewig nicht mehr
gesehen warnte vdma hatte
was fällt dir auch an diesem bild was
wollt ihr auch mal diesen biltgen er
genau genau passend habe ich hier ins
meer gespuckt und das sieht man sogar
darauf hier siehst du hier wo die maus
ist ach so war das trikot von dreck ja
noch mal den daumen zu nochmal den augen
zu
genau dazu und auch was aber das war
jetzt schon wieder unter volllast oder
ja ich weiß auch nicht ich bei mir ist
immer so der kopf warten wir doch augen
zu einmal noch die augen zu hacker nicht
wo diese bilder und wieder auf was das
wirklich gut
ich würde niemals nein das weiß ich
nicht aber ich würde das jetzt glaube
ich nicht können weil jetzt hast du mich
die aufgabe jetzt tauschen wir damit die
position schon mal einen test gut
bestanden jetzt kannst du mir nämlich
von deinem instagram bilder zeigen und
wir stellen das ganze aber für mich also
du musst dich jetzt auf dieser seite
sitzt also leute wir sind jetzt hier auf
dem instagram account von marie aber
wirklich ein schöner account erstmal und
jetzt darfst du halt bilder auswählen
von die ok ja das gut ist er hat gemacht
ich damit bisher schon so feiere sie war
dass wenn du die augen auf hass unseres
geöffnet ist du mir ein junger recke ist
ja das wollen wir testen leute auf
meinen kopf gegangen ich habe erstmal
draußen geguckt weil ich das so weil du
bist so weit unten schöne füße auf jeden
fall aber ich finde auch wirklich hier
die häuser im hintergrund extrem ein
schöner aussicht dies zu du kannst auch
auf gesicht das ist das eigentlich ein
bild das sagt ja das war der schlüssel
also ich hätte ehrlich zu sein gedacht
dass es deutlich schlimmer ist ja
vielleicht ist mir das jetzt auch gar
nicht so wirklich oder uns das jetzt gar
nicht so wirklich aufgefallen
aber ich gucke auf jeden fall auch bei
bildern ziemlich schnell direkt einfach
ins gesicht das ist ja das war ich
dachte hey wie mach ich jetzt dahin
geguckt oder nicht jetzt bin ich vom
video dahinter switch oder video das tut
mir aber leid da konnte ich dann
irgendwo anders hin
man kann immer zur seite gucken ok jetzt
noch zum schluss ich muss sagen bei
videos das ist halt wirklich schwieriger
glaub ich mach du das mal bitte jetzt
hier ganz kurz darauf war ich zeig dir
hat ein video oder ein
das ist ja okay jetzt kannst du dir auf
machen ja darauf schon aber guck mal
siehst du dass wir das mal aus weil ich
wenn ich trinke meinen augen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt sehen kann ich würde so
konzentriert sich aber auch darauf dass
du die ganze welt doch das mittlere bis
richtig und sozusagen werden zeigt mir
ein video von einem attraktiven tüten
dann gucke ich auch woanders nennen aber
nicht bei denen das sind doch hier die
erfolgreichsten tik tok leute das war's
auch schon aber ich habe es mir um
ehrlich zu sein deutlich krasser
vorgestellt also das ist halt viel
schönes tor
ich habe mir deutlich schwieriger
vorgestellt aber so ist das ich würde
sagen hast du irgendwas zu melden
lasst doch noch um da und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder oder übermorgen da gibt es
wieder ein normales video von mir oder
trekkingtouren